Україна каже, що не може чекати, поки війна припиниться,
щоб почати відбудовувати свою країну.
Але коштів на відбудову стає все менше.
Ось чому Україна намагається заручитися підтримкою Заходу
не лише для поставок зброї, а й для допомоги на реконструкцію.
Британський фінансист і політичний активіст американського походження Білл Браудер
колись мав найбільший портфель іноземних інвестицій у Росії.
Я запитав його, якою мірою заморожені активи російського Центробанку
можуть бути використані для відновлення України.
Отже, Білле, якою мірою заморожені активи російського Центробанку
можуть бути спрямовані на відновлення України?
На мій погляд, перш ніж говорити про реконструкцію, має закінчитися війна.
І ми зараз перебуваємо в певному вирішальному моменті, коли в України закінчуються боєприпаси та ресурси.
Захід, який обіцяв підтримувати стільки часу, скільки буде потрібно, тепер вагається.
Ми бачили, як угорці заблокували допомогу у 50 мільярдів доларів із фондів ЄС.
Ми бачили, як якась невелика група ультраправих республіканців блокувала кошти США.
І тому це справді більше питання про те, як Україна виграє війну і які кошти їй потрібні, щоб виграти війну.
Тому я б сказав, що заморожені російські активи мають бути використані в першу чергу для захисту.
А коли закінчиться війна, тоді можна говорити про відбудову.
Про які суми тут йдеться? Це сотні мільярдів?
Ніхто точно не знає. Бракує прозорості.
Багато країн не називають суми, але ми маємо десь від 300 до 350 мільярдів доларів
резервів російського Центробанку на Заході, у Сполучених Штатах, Великобританії та ЄС.
І в багатьох інших місцях. Це викликає масу запитань.
Перш за все, тому що кожна країна має свої рішення щодо конфіскації цих грошей.
Але як з фінансової, так і з моральної точки зору зрозуміло,
що Росія повинна заплатити за шкоду, яку вона завдала.
Як їх можна конфіскувати?
По-перше, гроші вже заморожені.
Якби ви запитали мене, скажімо, три роки тому, до того, як ЄС заморозив резерви російського Центробанку
я б відповів, що немає політичної волі це зробити.
Але вони заморозили ці гроші.
Тепер їх потрібно конфіскувати.
Багато людей кажуть: що це дасть?
Це створює невизначеність. Як щодо суверенного імунітету російських грошей тощо.
Але мій аргумент полягає в тому, що Росія настільки порушила міжнародні правила,
вторгнувшись в Україну, що можна навести чіткий юридичний аргумент
для конфіскації цих грошей.
І найголовніше те, що ці гроші або підуть з нашої кишені, або з кишені росіян.
Тому Путін повинен заплатити раніше, ніж ми заплатимо за його війну.
Що найгірше може статися, коли справа доходить до фінансової стабільності
і викачування такої кількості грошей одночасно?
Ті, хто нагнітає страх кажуть:
якщо ці гроші будуть конфісковані, то всі відмовляться від євро, доларів, стерлінгів і швейцарських франків.
Чому?
Бо вони подумають, що це ненадійні валюти.
Але тоді куди вони збираються подіти свої гроші?
Вони збираються вкладати їх в Китай чи Саудівську Аравію?
Це якийсь абсурдний аргумент і дуже обмежений аргумент казати,
що люди через це не будуть тримати долари чи євро.
Так, звичайно, якщо ви збираєтеся вторгнутися до сусіда та завдати шкоди
на сотні мільярдів доларів, можливо, ви не будете зберігати свої гроші в євро та доларах.
Але я думаю, що це здебільшого не впливає на фінансову стабільність.
І що цікаво, люди, які це кажуть, політики, а не фінансисти.
Я все своє життя працюю на фінансових ринках.
І я можу вам сказати, що долар і євро
залишаться резервними валютами після того, як це буде зроблено.
Деякі люди кажуть, що це створить небезпечний прецедент.
Але чи не було б це дуже сильним сигналом для Росії та інших,
що буде, якщо починати війни?
Дійсно, головним несподіваним наслідком цього є те,
що це діятиме як потужний стримуючий фактор для Китаю не йти на Тайвань.
Якщо у вас є країна з великими валютними резервами і плани зробити щось жахливе,
то ви можете вирішити: ці валютні резерви, мабуть, цінніші для нас,
ніж будь-який агресивний план, який ми маємо щодо вторгнення в іншу країну.
Тому я б сказав, що це прецедент, який полягає в тому,
що якщо ви вторгнетеся до своїх сусідів,
то не зможете зберегти свої гроші.
Тим часом між різними країнами в ЄС точаться дебати.
Німеччина, Італія, Бельгія, Франція переймаються лише скеруванням прибутків,
отриманих від цих заморожених активів,
які в деяких випадках складають приблизно 3 мільярди євро.
Це справді цікава річ.
Європейський Союз вирішив забрати частину грошей Росії,
конфіскувати частину цих резервів.
Але в той момент, коли ви конфіскуєте 1% чи 3% - ви вже перейшли рубікон.
Тож навіщо конфіскувати 2%, якщо можна конфіскувати 100%?
Україні потрібні гроші. Росія завдала шкоди.
Ви вже перетнули межу.
Це просто здається непотрібним дитячим кроком,
бо мені зрозуміло, що через деякий час буде політична воля конфіскувати всі гроші.
А як щодо законності всього цього? Можете пояснити?
Російський уряд буде кричати про криваве вбивство,
що це порушення закону.
Що це гроші, які належать суверенній державі - Росії,
вони захищені суверенним імунітетом і так само як посольства є недоторканними.
Західні юристи збираються аргументувати це правом і контрзаходами.
Якщо ви вторглися в чужу країну і завдали збитків на 300, 400 мільярдів чи трильйонів доларів,
то ви повинні відшкодувати ці збитки країні, в яку ви вторглися.
У світі є багато ситуацій, коли виникають колізії в законах.
І тут досить ясно, що виникає конфлікт права,
де суверенний імунітет перевершується законом і контрзаходами.
Це той аргумент, який наведуть юристи.
А як щодо погроз з боку Росії відповісти розправою,
коли йдеться про арешт активів?
Чи в змозі Росія конфіскувати будь-які активи?
Федеральна резервна система США не зберігає свої рублі в російських банках.
Тому не думаю, що це станеться.
Але я спілкувався зі старшим керівником корейської компанії Hyundai.
Вони інвестували 3 мільярди доларів у виробництво автомобілів у Санкт-Петербурзі,
і були змушені продати їх задарма якомусь росіянину.
Тому примусове позбавлення власності з боку приватного сектора вже відбулося.
Справа не в тому, що західні корпоративні активи зараз під загрозою.
Вони або були добровільно ліквідовані цими західними компаніями,
або їх експропріював російський уряд ще до того, як це сталося.
Що ще може зробити Росія?
Вони можуть кричати і плюватися, робити все, що захочуть.
Але це не просто допомога Україні.
Це спосіб покарати Путіна.
Ми повинні покарати його за те, що він зробив.
Йому потрібно заплатити високу ціну.
Його люди мають зрозуміти, що це відбувається,
бо ви вторглися в сусідню країну і вбиваєте її людей.
Ви критик Кремля, але ви також є чи були великим інвестором в Росії.
Як би ви себе почували, побачивши, як усі ці активи,
усі ці гроші раптово переводять з Росії в Україну?
Я думаю, що зітхнув би з полегшенням.
Я вважаю, що це буде морально правильно.
Україна відчайдушно намагається встати на ноги.
І перш ніж ми почнемо надсилати наші гроші з Заходу,
Путін повинен заплатити за війну, яку він спричинив.
Українці повинні отримати гроші Путіна, щоб дати відсіч.
І це виглядає як єдиний хороший і чесний вчинок.
Цікаво, коли я говорю про це публічно, у Twitter, то відповідь одностайна, що це правильно.
А на Заході не можуть зрозуміти, чому цього досі не зроблено.
Скільки грошей потрібно Україні на реконструкцію? Я читав про понад 400 мільярдів євро.
Я бачив цифри від 400 мільярдів до трильйона.
Усе залежить від того, як вимірювати збитки і яку реконструкцію потрібно зробити.
І ми ще далеко не закінчили цю війну.
Путін дав зрозуміти, що він продовжуватиме.
Тож якою б не була оцінка збитків, це лише тимчасовий захід.
І збитки там стануть ще гіршими.
Щодня тривають ракетні удари з боку Росії по Україні.
Реальність така, що приватні інвестори тут, у Давосі,
спочатку дивитимуться на повернення своїх інвестицій і пов’язані з цим ризики.
Але чи державам потрібно активізуватися?
Так. Коли приватний сектор не працює,
тоді має втручатися державний сектор.
Це ситуація, коли для виживання України потрібні державні кошти.
І Захід, і Європа, і Сполучені Штати, і Великобританія надавали кошти,
і їм потрібно продовжувати надавати їх.
Але не лише платники податків наших країн мають надавати ці кошти.
Так само як США, Великобританія збільшує фінансування,
щоб спробувати заповнити цю прогалину.
ЄС також намагається.
Як би ви переконали американських політиків продовжувати цю підтримку?
Я думаю, що більшість американських політиків, яких я знаю, повністю на боці України.
Тож не думаю, що це довгострокова проблема прямо зараз.
Гадаю, що Конгрес США знайде спосіб забезпечити 63 мільярди доларів,
які були обіцяні цього року.
Але невідомо, що станеться, коли в листопаді цього року оберуть нового президента.
Колишній президент Трамп зараз є фаворитом на виборах.
Він сказав, що закінчить війну за один день.
Під цим він має на увазі, що припинить фінансування України.
І якщо це станеться, то чи є у Європи ресурси, щоб збільшити допомогу?
І, до речі, повернімося до заморожених російських резервів.
Я міг би навіть описати їх як "страхування від Дональда Трампа".
Поясніть чому?
Якщо Дональд Трамп збирається відрізати Україну від фінансування,
а Україні потрібні будуть кошти, то тут є одна велика купа грошей
- ці резерви російського Центробанку в розмірі 300 з гаком мільярдів доларів,
які можна використати для заповнення прогалини, яку залишить Дональд Трамп.
Як би ви підсумували настрої тут, у Давосі, коли йдеться про підтримку України?
Я думаю, що люди втомилися. Це триває вже давно.
Було багато мрій про те, що війна швидко закінчиться
і все повернеться на свої місця.
Люди відволікаються, тому що на Близькому Сході триває друга війна.
Я приїжджаю сюди вже 28 років,
і я думаю, що рівень занепокоєння щодо геополітичних подій,
песимізм щодо геополітичних подій настільки високий, як ніколи раніше.
Білле, чи є щось, що дає вам надію у цій війні в Україні?
Я б сказав, що всі недооцінюють українців.
Ми всі думали, що українці здадуться через три дні, а війська Путіна будуть марширувати Києвом.
Цього не сталося.
Українці дали відсіч і билися так, як ми ніколи до цього не бачили, щоб хтось так бився.
І вони воюють з дуже поважної причини.
Бо якщо вони не воюватимуть, то загинуть.
Російська окупація така ж страшна, як смерть.
І українці зробили багато успішних речей.
Навіть маючи обмежені ресурси, вони фактично нейтралізували Чорноморський флот Росії.
Вони змогли експортувати зерно.
Пам’ятаєте, ще минулого року в Давосі у цей час ми хвилювалися
через продовольчу кризу через те, що там робила Росія.
Я бачив неймовірну військову тактику українців
з використанням безпілотників вартістю 500 доларів проти танків
вартістю 5 мільйонів доларів.
І тому ми не повинні недооцінювати те, що дуже рішуче,
дуже відважне населення, яке бореться за своє виживання,
зробить з корумпованою, деморалізованою військовою силою з Росії.
Білле Браудер, було приємно з вами поспілкуватися.
Дякую.